Humans might have built civilizations,
but insects own the world.
After all, over half of all
known species are insects.
So if they all suddenly
vanished, you'd notice.
No more summers of singing
cicadas and flickering fireflies.
No bees to pollinate apple,
cherry, peach, or almond trees.
No one to make honey.
A world without insects means a world
with empty grocery-store shelves.
But that would be just the
beginning of our problems.
Now, it's impossible to say
exactly what would go down,
but here's a worst-case
scenario of what could happen
if all the insects disappeared.
There are a few insects most people
would be happy to see vanish.
Like mosquitoes.
They kill hundreds of
thousands of people every year
by transmitting malaria, West Nile virus,
and other diseases.
But if they disappeared tomorrow,
we might actually miss them.
There are over 3,000 species
of mosquitoes on Earth,
all of which are food to birds,
bats, frogs, and other animals.
No more mosquitoes means these creatures
and the animals that eat
them could go hungry.
The same goes for the dreaded cockroach,
a protein-packed meal for birds, rodents,
and even humans in some
parts of the world.
If we lost all 4,400 species of roach,
entire ecosystems would
struggle to survive.
Believe it or not, we'd have
even worse troubles ahead
since we'd face a serious poop problem
without one of the world's
greatest recyclers,
the dung beetle.
You see, history has taught
us exactly what happens
when these critters can't do their job.
Back in 1788, the British
introduced cattle to Australia,
and these cows pooped a lot.
Each one poops enough to fill
five tennis courts every year.
But while the dung beetles back in Britain
would eat and break down cow poo,
the native Australian beetles
wouldn't touch the stuff
because they evolved to munch
only on dry, fibrous marsupial dung.
So the cow poop piled up.
By 1960, the cattle had
carpeted 500,000 acres
of pasture in dung.
That's enough to cover
over half of Rhode Island,
and while a little bit of
poop is great for fertilizer,
this ocean of dung would
flood plants with nitrogen,
making it impossible for anything to grow.
So, imagine if all 8,000
species of dung beetle,
plus other doo-dining insects,
like flies, vanished worldwide.
The land would be knee-deep in...you know.
Farmland, forest, and
desert would all collapse,
and floating throughout
would be loads of corpses.
You see, most animals
won't eat dead bodies.
That's where flesh-eating
beetles, aka dermestids,
and other corpse-munching insects come in.
Over 500 species of these grisly
undertakers live worldwide,
devouring dead flesh until
nothing but bone remains.
Without them, there would
be fewer custodians around
to clean up the mess.
Sure, there would still be hungry vultures
and bacteria around to help,
but it wouldn't be enough.
So, that's where we could end
up in an insect-less world.
Starving to death while drowning
in a sea of poop and corpses.